on dit de montréal télé la ville aux
cent clochers mais elle est aussi et
surtout la ville humilié de balcons
frontière entre les voisins et notre
intimité lieu de quotidiens et ça tombe
bien parce que c'est là que la chasse
balcon veut ramener la musique
traditionnelle du québec sait qui on est
qui on est et un vent qui commence est
devenu jusqu'au mas arriver jusqu'à
aujourd'hui je pense que c'est important
de sortir sur notre balcon et de jouer
cette musique lors de fêtes avec tout le
monde ça leur donne l'occasion d'abord
un petit air de briques traditionnelles
or cabanac depuis le début mai et
jusqu'à la fin juin catherine planait et
ses amis musiciens donnent des concerts
de musique traditionnelle sur les
balcons le vendredi soir toutes les
semaines la chasse balcon change
d'arrondissement
catherine planète travaille actuellement
sur un mémoire de maîtrise en
communication à l'uqam
la question centrale de sa thèse comment
revitaliser la musique traditionnelle
elle a donc tenté ici une expérience
inspiré par les cajuns de la région de
lafayette où j'ai passé une couple
d'années en louisiane
c'est que c'est vraiment les gens
sortent naturellement spontanément sur
leur balcon
j'utilise images du balcon mais les gens
sortent de chez eux fascinant avec leurs
instruments puisqu'il joue c'est un
répertoire commun qui est leur musique
traditionnelle facteurs la musique
traditionnelle fait partie du quotidien
des gens qui en est un répertoire commun
ça crée des liens l'hypothèse aucun des
recherches de la violoniste c'est qu'une
musique traditionnelle vivante créé la
fête et que la fête systèmes sociaux
plus solides théorique qui se vérifie
ici
j'en ai tellement naze n'est pas
concerné que par les ordinateurs par les
humaine
peut-être par texto puis les gens sont
surpris souvent quand ils arrivent c'est
un peu presque un choc de plus que dans
un autre mode d'interagir avec les gens
quand catherine demande aux gens de se
mettant en père pour danser des foyers
petite gêne mais s'est dissipée ça prend
15 secondes c'est ça qui est beau
ça rappelle nos racines j'aime dessous
on a chanté tout le monde ensemble ont
eu du plaisir
le train de rentrer chez eux puis la
semaine prochaine aux loisirs salue ici
milite dubreuil radio canada montréal